it's always good to have a rubber leg on
hand now this just isn't any rubber leg
this is a high-tech ballistics gel model
of a human leg ballistics gel closely
simulates the same density and viscosity
of human tissue so whatever happens to
this leg is what would happen to my leg
if attacked by a wild boar I've got a
couple more screws I think we should put
in here and Lee's holding some feral
hogs he captured earlier in a pen and
I'm gonna get inside the pen to see what
kind of damage they'll do to the leg all
right the ballistic gel legs are now
attached to a protective shield all I
have to do is approach an angry wild
boar he has an enclosure now are you
gonna just get behind the door I'm gonna
let you in and you're on your own okay
wait a second he gets you down and
starts killing it we got TV are you
ready I'm just um I'm just thinking
you're worried about me aren't you well
can I go it well I don't like this
you're getting up out of there no I'm
just getting up where I can be up the
gate try to work the gate ready come on
use your legs put your legs in the hole
where is he
y'all right here no wait a minute no no
no no no wait a minute
now you go in there good no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait a minute
getting me ready I'm afraid he'll come
around the back side and get me
I seriously I'm not sure I can do this
he's doing a good job you know that
right he's intimidating me I faced him
16-foot crocodiles giant pythons and
Komodo dragons but this animals got me
really scared get on out there don't
know what you think for you for taking
fight oh he's biting it he bit the leg
that time big gash over here yeah I know
the human leg is gone the foot in the
leg are gone he ripped it open there and
there beneath this hole is this
laceration right here that was caused by
the tough look at that that's deep
I can't imagine putting my hands on a
wild one that's not fenced in